One of the things I saw a lot in my comments
because I read them all was, well, I have
no money.
I'm like, I lived my whole life with no money,
but I figured it out.
You're not only speaking investing in yourself
is the best thing you can do.
Folks, if you don't have your money right,
the people you should spend your time with
is customers.
Want to be happy?
Build a life, not just a business.
So today, let's live your best, believe life,
and learn how to earn more money with these
practical tips.
Okay, let's get off with step number one.
Flip stuff with Gary Vee.
One of the things I saw a lot in my comments
because I read them all was, well, I have
no money.
I'm like, I lived my whole life with no money,
but I figured it out.
I would just buy, I would buy garage sales,
and it just got me going, I love it.
It's like a hobby of mine to go garage sales.
So I'm doing that with clothes.
I used to do it with clothes.
Dude, the met guys, especially like a stylish
kid, like if you're a flavor, if you're listening
right now, and you don't have money, but you're
cool or you got flavor, you got swag, you
got style.
If you just spend your life in goodwill, and
in thrift stores, yeah.
And buy that you think is fresh, and then
wear it and take a selfie and put it on eBay
for me times the price, like I see every day,
they amount of people that buy $3 T-shirts
and sell them for $35 on eBay and Etsy.
And Facebook Marketplace is enormous.
There's no excuse in America to say you have
no money, even if you're in the deepest, poorest
places, because if you can literally get a
dollar, you can buy your first T-shirt at
Goodwill, and get it up for 15 bucks on Facebook,
because you know what's funny?
What's funny is everybody's got a smartphone.
Like you go into the poorest place.
Isn't America?
And everybody's got a smartphone, which means
you have the internet.
I mean, listen, the homeless.
You've got people all over on homeless, smartphones.
I get emails every day.
I'm homeless, I watch you in YouTube.
So, I don't know, I really, in listen, of
course there's 1% that don't.
And that's what's always fascinating to me.
The 1% that populates, like, what about my
aunt?
I'm like, cool, I get it.
But I'm trying to address 99.9% of people,
and the garage still thinks, been huge, by
the way, huge.
I have tens of thousands of tweets, emails,
DMs, messages from people over the last 100
days, who are completely inspired by the show,
and are making significant money, and significant
comes in all forms.
Do you know what it's like to make an extra
200 bucks a month?
When you're not doing well financially, huge,
huge, huge, like, it matters.
It's also fun for 50% of people.
Like, that's the- Wow, watch the videos, and
I'm watching, like, go in your getting, you're
picking up these stuff to animals.
You know what this is gonna sell for?
40 bucks, 50 bucks.
And seven bucks, like, I get pumped.
Like, buying something for a quarter, selling
it for 11 on eBay, with the fees, with all
the bullshit that everybody makes fun of me
in the comments for, what about the gas?
All that, like, I'm still like, I mean, six
bucks.
I bought it for a quarter, I sold it for 11,
net six bucks, or I can be, for my couch right
now watching Netflix.
Like, if you complain and you're unhappy,
I will spend my career suffocating the living
shit that of you.
Step number two, invest in yourself with warm
buffet.
You're not only speaking, investing in yourself
is the best thing you can do.
Anything that improves your own talent.
So nobody can take that away from me.
They can run up huge deficits in the dollar,
and they will come worth far less.
You can have all kinds of things happen, but
if you've got talent yourself, and you've
maximized your talent, you've got a terrific
asset.
That doesn't mean everybody should go to college,
but it does mean that any way you find to
improve communication skills are an armistly
important.
I mean, I took a Dale Carnegie course that
I paid $100 for, and it was worth a college
degree.
At least, I thought it was.
Maybe this interview will come to school otherwise.
Also, if you want to have confidence, like
Gary V. Warren Buffett, Dan Locken, others
check out my 254 confidence series.
It's free, the link is in the description
below.
The reason people don't put themselves in
a position to fail, the reason people aren't
patient is they value other people's opinions
too much.
It's important to associate with people that
are better than yourself.
After you practice martial, you've developed
this natural self-confidence, not cockiness,
but you've developed this natural self-confidence.
Step number three, master marketing with Joe
Polish.
That was a dead broke carpet cleaner, live
in off credit cards, work in hard, struggling,
doing a good job, operating with integrity,
really cared, but there's no relationship
between being good and getting paid.
And so until you actually learn how to sell
what it is that you're off whatever it is.
Service business, internet business, being
an author, speaker, doctor, it doesn't matter.
You're in the marketing business, and the
marketing business, you're in really the relationship
business.
You can either be a transaction, marketer,
or you can be a relationship marketer.
And there's always, as you know, there's always
more money in relationships.
And I grew up incredibly shy and credibly,
introverted, so I'm kind of like an introvert
that learned how to talk to people, because
if you don't, nothing happens.
I think marketing is the most important thing.
Just like hold your breath for three minutes
and see how well you do, hold it for five
minutes, hold it for ten minute, you can't,
you'll die.
Marketing is like that for business.
If people's businesses are struggling, if
they're missions, and this is not just business,
entrepreneur, this is every air of your life.
I mean, if you have a partner, you did some
sort of marketing.
There's something you did to meet the person,
position yourself.
So to answer the question, selling is what
you do when you're on the phone or face to
face with somebody.
Marketing is what you do to get someone on
the phone or face to face with you so that
they're properly positioned.
So the key, the word positioning is really
critical.
So by the time that they actually talk with
you or visit your store or go to your website
or see you speak, they're pre-interested,
pre-motivated, pre-qualified, and pre-disposed
to do business with you.
And I've said that a million times.
And I drilled that into my head.
It's all about pre-interested, pre-motivated,
pre-qualified, pre-disposed.
And if people are set up that way, the whole
job is selling that selling is much easier.
Frankly, if you have to rely on talking someone
into something, then you just aren't doing
any marketing.
Step number four, execute an ideas immediately
with Dan Locke.
Most people, they let the ego get in the way
of success.
It's very easy, notice people say, I know
that I know that, I know that, what you don't
know, shit.
You do not know it.
How do you know when you know something?
If you don't live it, you don't know it.
So those three words are very, very dangerous.
And they destroy your potential, they destroy
your success.
Why?
Because the minute you say, I know that, your
brain shuts down, you're not listening anymore.
And you're like, okay, I know that, I don't
need to listen any further.
You're not paying attention.
So what you know it?
So what did you know it?
It's not about knowing it.
I could tell you this, I am not an original
thinker.
Let me just tell you the whole world.
I am not an original thinker.
There's nothing new about what I do.
Everything I learned from the Pauline Hill,
I'll just accept it for entrepreneurs, think
and grow rich, proven masters from the past,
my mentors.
There is absolutely nothing new about what
I say and about what I do.
I am a synthesizer.
I take different ideas, I put it together.
The only difference between me and everybody
else is I don't say, I know that.
What do I say?
I say, I use that.
I use that.
That's a, those three words are much more
powerful than I say, I know that.
Because when I use it, I own it.
It is mine.
I didn't say that, everybody else.
There's thinking on the ideas that are learning
about it, I know that I know that, I know
that, you want, I ask, how can I use that?
How can I use that?
I implement.
The only difference between me and everybody
else, I can execute a better than most people.
I use it better than most people.
There's the only difference.
And so if you're just watching a video, you
watch 1500 videos, you don't use, I can use
one video, I can read one book, I can take
ideas and I implement, execute immediately
and execute well.
That's only difference.
And step number five, the last one before
a very special bonus clip is expands your
network with grant card number.
Expand your network.
Okay, Jim Rhone said, you're the equivalent
of the five people you spend most time with.
Folks, if you don't have your money right,
the people you should spend your time with
is customers.
Now your family, now your friends, unless
your friends are buying from you, your family's
buying from you, you should spend your five,
the five people you spend your time with every
day should be different people, they should
be custom.
After that, to create a network, you need
to expand outside of your zip code.
You need new friends.
You need to collaborate with people.
You need new connections, new ideas.
That's why this mastermind that we're doing
the bootcamp I'm doing.
In what 10 days?
You're gonna meet 300 people that it will
be as valuable to meet the people in the room.
How they think, how they operate, how they
act, what they're doing, what's working, what's
not working.
Create a expand, a network.
Okay?
You do not need more time with your family.
You need less time with your family and more
time with a bigger family.
My wife and I always talk about, let's expand
our family beyond the people that we were
born with.
I need new ideas.
I need new thoughts.
I need to know about new parts of the world,
new expansion.
Now I've got a special partnership with Tidelope
as on how to sell simple household items.
Before that, it's time for the three-point
landing questions.
Let's go from just watching another video
to taking action here we go.
Question number one, what idea do you need
to act on immediately?
Number two, what step will you take this week
to invest in yourself?
And number three, how will you expand your
network this month?
Okay, how do I make money online?
People always ask me how I make money.
And I thought I'd just show you some actual
screenshots on my phone on different products,
different businesses I have.
Here's today, one of my companies here, 17,384
dollars.
Today alone made 715,000 in the last month.
Selling simple household items.
You know I like books, that's how much I sold
in books.
And I got another company, you know I like
glasses.
So we sell glasses, sleep glasses, I'll show
you a little screenshot of that one.
This is a Shopify.
This month it sold 17,000 today, it's done
1,300 bucks.
There's an airplane coming in.
We give you a tour.
And I'm going to share with you four simple
steps that you can get started, making money
online today.
Now you're not going to start out, making
$700,000 a month like I'm doing.
It took me a while to build up, but telling
you it's easier to start now than it's ever
been.
Because when I got started, you didn't have
Shopify.
Amazon wasn't easy to sell on.
You didn't have stripe to collect credit card,
number, you know, to collect the process payment.
I'm going to show you the four ways that gets
started.
If you want within 24 hours, making money
online.
Now like I said, it's not a get rich quick
scheme, but trust me.
There's simple household items around your
house.
$700,000 in the last month, I've sold a books
and book related things.
Educational stuff.
More, this is just one business.
You could sell cano people selling candles,
making 100 grand.
I know guys selling candles, I'm going to
make a couple of million bucks.
Everywhere you look.
So step number one, to make money online,
find a household item that's interesting to
you.
That's step number one.
Find a household item that's related to what
you do on a day to day basis.
Like I said, I sold seven, what I still in
glasses, 1300 today.
And then this is just not showing Amazon.
Amazon did about $3,000,000 a day.
$5,000 a day.
And I also do stuff related to sleeping well,
because everybody's got a bed and got a sleep.
Step number two, decide if you want to sell
using a website that you can build on Shopify,
click funnels, or you can just use Amazon.
You need to decide between those three.
Step number three, okay.
You got to connect them and you got to get
away to collect money.
So you can either use strike, brain tree,
or if you sell on Amazon, they have built
in.
You can process through them.
I don't recommend paypal as your only source.
Sometimes, depends.
Step number four, once you got those, is you
need to light label the products.
So you don't want to have to create.
If you want to sell glasses or if you want
to sell cosmetics or if you want to sell tables,
you don't actually manufacture them, at least
not to start.
So there's a simple way that you can use what's
called white labeling or drop shipping to
take products that people have and put your
own label and brand on it.
With that said, you can be up and going with
those four steps.
Literally, if you start early enough today,
you can do it today.
Be up and running.
Now, like I said, you got to get sales.
That comes.
If you know how to do it, Amazon literally
has, I forget how many sales a day, 80 million
sales a day, different items sold.
So if you do well on the Amazon ecosystem,
people will find you, especially if you know
how to rank there.
For some of you, you might be intimidated
by trying to make, you know, $715,000 a day,
by the way.
We've been making money.
While we were on this walk.
But we were on this walk made a couple hundred
bucks in the last couple minutes.
That's the beauty, by the way, of selling
online.
I call it robotic income.
Like robot never gets tired.
It just does the work.
If you build a website correctly using Shopify
or click funnels or Amazon, they never get
tired.
Those servers run.
As long as there's electricity, they're running.
And one of the cool things, if you want to
make a hundred grand a year, a lot of people
think it's hard to make a hundred grand a
year, it is if you have a nine to five job,
because you only work in eight hours a day.
But a robot never gets tired.
The body income, there's no end.
It can run 24 hours a day.
Did you know to make a hundred thousand dollars
a year, pull out a calculator and do the math.
Let me show you.
A hundred thousand dollars a year, okay?
Right there.
Divided by 365 days, because a robot, a website
can work nonstop, is $273 a day, right?
A hundred divided by 365 days.
Then how many days are there?
I mean, hours in a day?
Oh, we've got to make $11.41 a hour.
11 hours, 41 cents an hour.
You're making a hundred thousand dollars a
year.
If you want to learn seven ways to make money
while you sleep, go check out the video right
there next to me.
I think you'll enjoy it.
Continue to believe, and I'll see you there.
You want to create something that is meaningful
in that last.
Now that's your mindset and your approach.
And these seven things are going to help you.
You're able to make more money.